c'était une des grandes promesses de son
de sa campagne qui était de faire
émerger la société civile dans la
politique une voix dissonante par
rapport à une politique professionnelle
qui était effectivement très ronronnante
on s'est dit nous allons avoir une voix
fraîche nouvelles originales
capables de faire remonter les attentes
collective et on n'a vu ni rien comme
thème ni personne comme individualités
portant une que ça soit la
représentation d'un secteur
professionnel ou des aspirations
collectives particulière le/la
république en marche et un nom parti qui
n'existe que dans la dévotion à une
personne sans avoir su ou ou tu joues il
ya peut-être que je tendrais à penser
qu'il ya une grosse erreur de casting
née en partie de l'improvisation la
serbie il fallait faire vite et donc en
fait on a pris non pas la société civile
mais les deux groupes 2e 3e 4e couteaux
des parties déjà en place et finalement
on a la bonne chose en moins bien
[Musique]